comparemos las estructuras del etano y
el eterno eta no es un arcano con
terminación a n
y tiene la fórmula molecular de 2 h 6
por otro lado el eterno es un al que no
con terminación e n o y su fórmula
molecular es de 2 h 4 para una molécula
de 2 carbonos 6 hidrógenos es el máximo
número de hidrógenos que podría tener
entonces decimos que el etano está
completamente saturado de hidrógenos por
acá tenemos una molécula que tiene 2
carbonos pero sólo tiene 4 hidrógenos
entonces decimos que es
y saturado porque como tenemos dos
carbonos podríamos tener más hidrógenos
bueno pero ahora vamos a analizar a los
carbonos de estas moléculas y vamos a
empezar por el etano este carbono tiene
una hibridación sp3 y lo mismo sucede
con este otro carbono entonces el etano
tiene dos carbonos esp 3 y british a 2 y
sabemos que la geometría de los carbonos
hibrid izados sp3 es una geometría te
trae drica ok el etano tiene una
geometría te trae drica en sus dos
carbonos y de este lado en el eterno
estos dos carbonos están sp2 y british a
2 sp2 y brisa 2 y sabemos que la
geometría de los carbonos sp2 ibiza 2 es
una geometría tribunal plana que hay
tenemos una geometría tribunal plana en
estos dos carbonos
y ahora lo último que nos falta es ver
cómo es el enlace entre los carbonos
aquí tenemos un enlace sigma y los
enlaces sigmas tienen rotación libre a
lo largo del enlace entonces podemos
tener distintas conformaciones de esta
molécula aunque hay porque tenemos
rotación libre a lo largo de este enlace
tenemos rotación libre a lo largo del
enlace sigma entre nuestros dos carbonos
pero ahora si vemos el enlace del eterno
este enlace entre los dos carbonos es un
enlace doble y sabemos que los enlaces
dobles no permiten rotación en el este
no no tenemos rotación libre por lo cual
no vamos a tener distintas
conformaciones del este no lo que hay no
tenemos rotación libre por lo cual no
tenemos otras con formaciones y eso
afecta la estructura de nuestros al que
nos aquí a la izquierda tenemos un eta
no y si nos fijamos en sus dos carbonos
sp3 civilizados podemos ver la geometría
tetraedro
a su alrededor y aquí tenemos este
enlace sigma entre los dos carbonos por
lo tanto podemos ver que hay rotación
libre para el eterno por acá nuestros
dos carbonos y british a 2 sp2 tienen
una geometría plana a su alrededor
entonces si la movemos por acá aquí
podemos ver que en efecto es una
geometría plana y no hay rotación libre
por este enlace doble porque hay porque
los enlaces para los enlaces dobles no
permiten rotación como podemos ver esta
molecular no la podemos rotar podemos
clasificar a los al que nos de acuerdo a
su grado de sustitución si tomamos un al
que no y le quitamos uno de sus
hidrógenos y colocamos en su lugar
un grupo r entonces lo que tenemos es un
al que no mono sustituido por aquí a la
derecha tenemos un ejemplo de un al que
no mono sustituido aunque tal vez quede
un poco más claro si colocamos los
hidrógenos que tiene esta molécula
sabemos que éste
bueno tiene dos hidrógenos y que este
otro carbono tiene un solo hidrógeno y
por acá tenemos un grupo alquilo en
lugar del otro hidrógeno que podría
tener este carbono porque tenemos un
grupo metilo así es que este es un
ejemplo de un al que no mono sustituido
si queremos poner el nombre de este al
que no podemos recordar un vídeo
anterior en el que explicamos cómo se
hace eso ok vamos a empezar diciendo que
este es el carbono 1
este es el carbono 2 y este es el
carbono 3
así es que aquí tenemos la cadena más
larga de carbonos y es de tamaño 3 y
este es un al que no por lo cual esta
molécula se llama propano propano bueno
ahora vamos a ver un al que no ni
sustituido por aquí en esta molécula
puse r
y reprima porque si estas dos puede ser
que sean iguales pero también pueden ser
distintas
en esta molécula en particular r y r
prima están enlazados al mismo carbono
pero eso no tiene que ser así por
ejemplo aquí r&r prima están enlazados a
carbonos distintos y además este no es
el único otro ejemplo por acá tenemos a
r ya ere prima también enlazados a
carbonos distintos pero observa que son
distintos en esta molécula los dos
grupos r están en lados opuestos del
doble enlace mientras que en este otro
ejemplo si dibujamos una línea paralela
al doble enlace los dos grupos se re
están del mismo lado del doble enlace
pero además sabemos que estas dos
moléculas no pueden rotar sobre su
enlace para formar la otra molécula
porque los enlaces dobles no permiten la
rotación
entonces aquí tenemos tres ejemplos
distintos de al que nos de sustituidos
bueno vamos a ver este al que no di
sustituido por acá y vamos a ponerle el
nombre así es que buscamos la cadena de
carbonos más grande que podemos
encontrar que incluya al doble enlace y
le queremos dar el número más pequeño a
nuestro enlace doble por lo que vamos a
empezar por aquí este es el carbono 1
este es el carbono 2 y este el carbono 3
la cadena de carbonos más larga que
encontramos tiene 3 carbonos y aquí
tenemos un enlace doble por lo que este
es un propinó pero además tenemos aquí
este grupo metilo enlazado al carbono 2
por lo que agregamos un 2 metil al
nombre y si nos preguntamos qué tipo de
al que no sustituido es bueno pues lo
más fácil es dibujar sus hidrógenos este
carbono está enlazado con dos hidrógenos
luego el otro carbono está enlazado con
dos grupos metilo entonces aquí tenemos
dos grupos aquí los que resultaron ser
el mismo son grupos metilo y los dos
están enlazados al mismo carbono
entonces es este tipo de al que no de
sustituido en el que los dos grupos al
kilos están enlazados al mismo carbono
ahora vamos a ver un al que no tres
sustituido entonces tenemos tres grupos
al kilos r r prima y r y prima y otra
vez estos tres grupos al kilos pueden
ser iguales o pueden ser distintos por
acá tenemos un ejemplo de un al que no
tres sustituido por aquí tenemos un solo
hidrógeno y tenemos tres grupos al qui
los tres grupos al kilos enlazados con
el doble enlace
si queremos escribir el nombre de esta
molécula tenemos que buscar la cadena de
carbonos más larga que contenga el doble
enlace
entonces por aquí tenemos el carbono 1 2
3 4 y 5 entonces tenemos un al que no
con una cadena de 5 carbonos por lo cual
esta molécula es un puente no y nuestro
enlace doble empieza en el carbono 2 por
lo cual este es un 2 centeno y
finalmente tenemos aquí
este grupo metilo que está enlazado al
carbono 2 entonces para terminar el
nombre tenemos que agregar 2 metil 2
metil 220 no y listo este es el nombre
de este al que no trees sustituido bueno
ahora vamos a ver un al que no te tras
sustituido tenemos aquí los grupos al
kilos r r prima r doble prima y r triple
prima que por aquí esta molécula es un
al que no tetra sustituido por aquí
tenemos el doble enlace estos son los
dos carbonos del doble enlace
y lo primero que vamos a hacer es
ponerle el nombre a esta molécula y ya
después vamos a ver porque es un al que
no te tras sustituido pero bueno este es
el carbono 1 y entonces tengo que seguir
la dirección del doble enlace para
llegar al carbono 2 y este es un ciclo
externo ya hemos visto en otros vídeos
cómo llamarles a estas moléculas
entonces por aquí simplemente voy a
poner ciclo externo y tenemos un grupo
metilo en el carbono uno y otro grupo
metilo en el carbono 2 entonces tenemos
que agregar 1/2 dimetil 1/2 dimetil
ciclo exc no es el nombre de este al que
no t tras sustituido y ahora sí vamos a
ver por qué éste tras sustituido por acá
para el carbono 1 tenemos este grupo
metilo y pues también tenemos esta parte
del ciclo hexano enlazado con el carbono
1 así es que este carbono tiene estos
dos grupos alquilo sen
2 y por acá el otro carbono también
tiene dos grupos al kilos tiene este
grupo metilo y esta porción del ciclo
hexano por eso es que esta molécula es
un al que no tendrá sustituido